what's going on guys this is rob and
I've actually got to go into work here
in the next few minutes but before i did
i thought i'd make a video and talk to
you guys some of the i said that i
should make the videos like long ways
like this so that it's not like straight
up and down it doesn't look as bad i
don't know if that really matters it all
but we're coming up on 50,000
subscribers and and this is crazy this
is this is nuts it's it's kind of
overwhelming you know I know that myself
Benny salen de we say it all the time
and I hope it doesn't wear too thin but
but we love you guys a lot and and we're
really hoping I love maybe Benny says
you know thinks about this as much as I
do but you know well I'm really hoping
that you guys that at least a good
number of you guys can make it up to
comic-con and see us because i don't
know maybe maybe seen people at
comic-con that are here to hang out that
are their hangout was like me and benny
and style and Dave maybe it'll like you
know verify that my channels as
successful as i hook it is you know
maybe it'll verify that that i don't
know that i've done done something
impactful you know that that maybe I'm
more than just a guy that makes videos
about comics I'm not really sure but you
know um it would just be fun you know to
hang out with you guys and to like nerd
out then talk about comics and often
will be I think it'd be pretty
interesting you know but it's it's just
it's one of these things where I think
that the beautiful thing about YouTube
the great thing about this whole YouTube
experience is that like we can all
interact so well and we can all do so
much cool stuff I don't know maybe I'm
having this existential crisis getting
50,000 subscribers but all I really know
is this you know it's all thanks to you
guys you know everything that's
happening now everything going to
comic-con and all this kind of stuff
there's all because of you guys and
again I really want you guys to be able
to join us there if you guys were around
New York if you guys are in New Jersey
if you guys are going to be at comic-con
hit us up you know just just say hey
look you know I'm gonna be a comic con
like
come see me and and yeah I mean we'll
definitely do what we can to try to make
it happen you know we'll set up a place
to for everybody become meet up at or
something but you know and for those of
you guys who can't make it if those of
you guys that they can't be at comic-con
with us my arm is getting always getting
sore from holding this camera for those
of you guys that can't make it to
comic-con with us um you know we're
going to be recording all kinds of
footage I'm going to be uploading
footage onto my youtube channel every
day just stuff that's going on around
here you know we're like walking around
eating food I don't know go checking in
to the airport it'll just be whatever it
is I feel like recording will be getting
uploaded what I'm also going to try to
do to you is I'm going to try to
schedule uploads so that I'll be able to
have videos that are still being
uploaded to my channel that guys
that's motorcycles allowed but i'll
still have videos being uploaded to my
channel so that you guys can have stuff
to watch while we're away doing comic
book stuff with regards to the whole
contest I think I'm actually gonna kind
of bring that to an end if I give it a
few more days but for the most part I
think I've gotten as many responses as
I'm going together they kind of came in
at first and then they started trickling
off a little bit there was maybe a
response a day or something like that
but but you guys are sitting so many
ideas oh my god you guys are send me
some ideas um you guys send me some
fantastic ideas and I don't even know
where to begin I've been going through
them all you know and looking through
them some of you guys ascent replies to
some of the guys i asked you guys to
like you know expand on the idea that
you would sent to me and you know and it
was it was a it was awesome so so those
those logos or whichever logo i choose
again is going to go on the t-shirts and
the hoodies all I kind of get said well
Cindy one of each and get you something
from comic-con but yeah I guess before I
get off here and before i go into work i
just want to say i love you guys you
guys are amazing you guys are so awesome
thank you for all the support and all
the videos that i've uploaded you guys
are so positive you guys are just so you
guys don't know you guys are just so
nice and I love you guys for that so um
anyway I hope this isn't like creepy
like to close to my face or anything but
I've never really done one of these one
of these things before one of these like
videos before so I don't know like how
I'm supposed to do this with an iphone
or anything all I really have for my
experience are like like rah hots iphone
which I don't know if you guys watch raw
hot side phone but he's the guy that
does the like rotten rotts magic or
whatever it is where he does like street
magic he's really fun he's really
entertaining but um but yeah so so yeah
I want to bounce off here I'm gonna head
into work and I'll catch you guys later
peace